When sporting teams and work teams,...
...have plans to improve themselves or simply have a vacancy,...
...the coach or manager usually calls in a specialist to find new talents.
In companies, that specialist is the HR or human resources manager.
Recruiting is a huge part of making great teams.
From the group of  wannabes, HR staff use their knowledge and experience...
...to find the best person for the job.
HR managers are a vital link in the company's overall structure,...
...making sure that the people match the company's purpose.
But human resources staff do much more than find stars for the team.
They provide expert advice to managers...
...about how they can improve their team's performance...
...and suggest training options to optimize staff potential.
HR staff also monitor well-being, look after safety needs...
...and sometimes act as intermediaries.
And importantly, they make sure people get paid fairly.
They then follow up to ensure when jobs change, so does the pay.
Keeping capable staff saves time and money in the long run,...
...so HR managers play a big part in staff retention.
In a big company, helping people along a successful career path is part of this responsibility.
HR managers can make a big difference when they connect the right people.
They help shape the business by facilitating change, then everyone benefits.